Great experiences on Android
TV are casual, cinematic,
and simple.
You can lean back on
the couch and enjoy
hundreds of movies,
TV series, and videos
from various sources.
But wait.
How can you find
your favorite movie
amongst thousands of
movies in your library?
Well, the answer is that
you can just search for it.
In fact, searching is something
that Android TV does really
well.
I'm Wayne Piekarski, a
developer advocate at Google,
and today, I'm going to show you
how search works on Android TV
and how you can surface the
great content of your app
to your users.
This here is the
Android TV home screen.
Users can easily
access the Search menu
and ask for anything
using their own voice
or via keyboard input.
The results are displayed
in a well organized form
and users have one click
access to launch the content.
This is a really cool feature.
So you might be worried
that your users won't
be able to find the content
contained within your app.
The good news is that
Android TV search
enables your app to surface
its content outside of the app.
Your users will be much
happier to easily find
what they're after, and in
turn, this will drive engagement
with your app.
Let's quickly look
at how search works.
Android TV will show the
search results from Google,
but it also queries locally
installed searchable apps
and combines these results.
Building a searchable
app on Android TV
is just the same as building a
searchable app on other Android
phones and tablets, so you can
use exactly the same Android
tools as what you're
already familiar with.
Let's talk about what
some of the steps
are to go and make this happen.
First, you have to let
Android framework know
that your app is searchable.
This is done by adding an
XML file with some metadata
in an XML resources
folder, like this one here.
So what does this file
look like, exactly?
Label is the name
of your app and it
should be the same as the name
applied to the Android label
attribute of your activity or
application manifest element.
This label is used to
identify your application
when providing search
results and to categorize it.
The search suggest authority
uniquely identifies
your content provider.
Therefore, this value must
match the authority string
provided in the
Android authorities
attribute of the AndroidManifest
provider element.
And search suggest intent
action is the default intent
action to be used when a user
clicks on a search result.
Mainly, this is a view
intent that we use here.
This IS a deep
link into your app
and should go straight
to the selected content.
Finally, since we want to
surface our results globally,
we need to set the include
global search attribute
value to true.
For more detailed information
of other attributes,
you can always refer to this
link in the Android developer
documentation.
Next, you need to define
a content provider
for the search results in
the AndroidManifest XML file.
As I mentioned earlier,
the content provider
should have the exact
same authority string
provided in search
suggest authority,
and it has to be
allowed to access
this provider from other apps.
The actual implementation
of the content provider
depends on you, and you can
find a step by step guide
for building a provider at
the Android developer site.
However, today, I've
got some tips for you
to help implementing a
search result provider.
Since the main purpose of
the search result provider
is providing search
results, you don't
need to implement methods
like insert or update, just
the query method.
All the necessary
constant strings
like URI path and
columns which you
might need to
implement a provider
are already defined in
the search manager class.
Some results, for example,
are RESULT_CARD_IMAGE, image,
which is used for
defining an image, poster,
or cover of your media,
CONTENT_TYPE for your media's
MIME type, and DURATION,
which includes time
information in milliseconds.
You can also define what
data should be passed back
to your app when a user
clicks on a search result
by setting an intent data
column value or a combination
of intent data ID
and a search suggest
intent data attribute in the
previous searchable element.
Therefore, in the
query method, you
should gather result data
from your data source
based on the query
string and then
map that data into the cursor
by using the pre-defined column
names.
The Android TV framework
will then take your cursor
and look it up using the same
column names that you used
and display nice looking
result cards using data
that you provide.
And that's it.
You can verify this
by installing your app
to the device, performing
a test query on Android TV,
and you find that the results
from your app are included.
I also have a
special tip for you.
If you've had the chance
to use Android TV devices,
you may have noticed this.
As you see here, the search
result itself came from Google,
but when a user
clicks this button,
a specific app is
launched directly.
We call this a watch action
link, and with your app,
you can take advantage
of this cool feature
and it's really easy to do.
When you provide data
for search results
and return enough
metadata to identify
that the media from
your app matches
the results from
Google, then Android TV
will automatically attach
the watch action link
on the search result card.
So keep this in mind.
Try to provide rich and
accurate metadata for your media
to assist this process.
And here's just one
last thing for you.
If you would like to
provide in app search
functionality in your app,
this is really easy as well.
Just override the on
search requested callback
in your TV activity and
the default search icon
will appear on the top of
your layout, like this.
Whenever a user
selects the Search icon
or clicks the Search button
on the remote control,
your callback will be invoked.
Inside the callback, you can
launch your own search result
activity, as shown
in this example here.
To make your life easier,
the Leanback Support Library
provides a search
fragment widget
which implements a main layout
for the search results screen,
and you can find out
more detailed information
about the Leanback Library
in this previous Dev Byte.
If you want to test the
concepts I just explained,
the code is available as a
sample at this link here.
If you want to learn more about
other interesting Android TV
features like recommendations,
the background manager,
you should definitely check out
the Android TV documentation
at the Android
developers website.
So that's it for today.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
I'm Wayne Piekarski.
Thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]